the Trump administration needs to start
its term in office by making very clear
that we will retaliate if China seizes
another underwater unmanned vehicle a
drone or any other American property in
the South China Sea or anywhere else in
order to do that we have to be very
credible which means having good
intelligence about the Chinese ships in
the area and our own capabilities the
ships that they usually harass are
unarmed American research and
surveillance vessels so what we need to
do is make sure that there are American
destroyers or frigates or other armed
vessels in the vicinity the Chinese take
the drone we stop them we do not let
them continue on their way
we shadow them if they begin to move and
we make clear that we are going to
pressure them in any way possible in
order to give up our property a
diplomatic de Marsh is not enough
especially when China feels that it can
get away with doing this with impunity
we may have to throw some elbows but the
message will become clear to China that
we mean it when we say we're going to
preserve freedom of navigation and
freedom of the high seas to learn more
about my take on Chinese threats to
maritime security check the links in the
description below also let us know what
other topics you'd like a EEI scholars
to cover in 60 seconds